I think they wanted me on that oh my
name is Larry Summers I am delighted to
welcome Jason Furman to the forum at the
Kennedy School Jason is probably the
preeminent economic policy thinker and
doer of his generation he has been a
stalwart of President Obama's
administration since eight months before
it began when he became the economic
policy director of Obama for America
subsequent to that he served as the
deputy director of the National Economic
Council for the first two years of the
Obama administration during the time
that I was head of the National Economic
Council and I have worked with many many
people none more able creative
hardworking analytical and political set
politically savvy than Jason Furman
subsequently he became assistant to the
president for Economic Policy working
within the National Economic Council
under Gene Sperling and then in August
of 2013 he became the chairman of the
President's Council of Economic Advisers
where he serves as the principal advisor
to the President on the economic
analysis of a very wide range of policy
issues and where he has become something
of a national Oracle on questions rate
ranging from the prospects for future
economic growth to understanding the
impacts of greater social inclusion on
economic performance to issues relating
to inequality as chairman of the Council
of Economic Advisers he bears primary
responsibility for the annual economic
report of the president Jason does all
of this following a although he is still
a young man distinguished economic
career in economic policy working at the
National Economic Council during
President Clinton's administration
working in the World Bank in the late
1990s serving as a visiting professor at
virtually every distinguished East Coast
University for a brief interval during
the 2000s and becoming a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution and the
director of the hamilton project for the
two years before the obama campaign
began jason is a great privilege to be
back with you and to welcome you to the
Kennedy School
thank you it's great to be back at
Harvard and try to live up to at least
one tenth of that introduction I should
say that Jason holds a bachelor's degree
a master's degree and a PhD degree from
Harvard University and he has made
Harvard and he has made Harvard proud
this is billed as a conversation between
Jason and me but my sentences are going
to be interrogative and I imagine his
will be declarative Jason what do you
make of the prospects for us economic
growth over the last five years the
unemployment rate has come down by
almost five percentage points and the
economy has only grown at below two and
a half percent so it has to be the case
that much or most of that growth is
cyclical coming with the five percentage
point reduction in unemployment and so
if the growth is two and a half percent
and even half of it is cyclical and one
can make a case that more of it is
cyclical isn't the evidence that we're
looking at a pretty serious issue of
slow economic growth going forward and
if that's right why didn't the economics
profession understand that a few years
ago when everybody was confidently
saying that potential growth for the US
economy was close to two and a half
percent so I would be one of the ways to
be an Oracle and economic policy by the
way is take anything
area would say about the economy and try
to frame it a little bit more
optimistically then he would have and on
this I would be cautiously optimistic
about the future of US economic growth
I'd be cautious because one we can never
be certain the most important factor in
growth is how much you innovate how many
new ideas you have and if there's
anything that's really hard to predict
its things people haven't thought of yet
and I'd be cautious also because I think
it depends on the choices we make the
choices we make in terms of investments
in infrastructure reforming our tax
system international trade education a
whole wide range of other factors unless
taken by any conviction around the
negative case which is the way you at
least framed your question or
provocation in part because I think the
last five years have been a very special
and unique time and not one that I would
extrapolate forward from it was in the
wake of the worst crisis since the Great
Depression that crisis took a really big
toll on business investment so if you
actually break down productivity growth
in the last five years the weakness has
not been in total factor productivity
the total amount of output you can get
for a given amount of capital and labor
inputs the weakness has been in business
investment and I think that's important
because I don't think the last five
years of business investment is a good
way to predict the next five or ten
years a business investment there's a
lot of reasons to think an economy
further away from a financial crisis
businesses more able to invest banks
more willing to lend an economy with
stronger demand that justifies and
merits stronger investment and less
uncertainty whole range of reasons to
think that we can't extrapolate out from
that so you know number one don't have
confidence in the negative side of the
case because I wouldn't extrapolate out
for the last five years number two I
look around at the economy and I see a
lot of really exciting developments I
see them in technology with
cloud computing and mobile devices with
advanced materials and nanotechnology
with personalized medicine and genomics
in the energy sector with extraction of
energy from unconventional sources as
well as reduction in uses and also a
dramatic slowdown in health costs and
health costs growth I think all of those
structural factors give me a decent
amount of cause for optimism about the
future let's be a little more precise
the adult population which traditionally
has grown at one and a half two percent
he's going to grow depending on exactly
how you measure it at about three tenths
of a percent over the next over the next
20 years labor force participation for
most groups has been trending downwards
even before there's even before there
was a recession and people work a bit
fewer hours each year just because that
seems to be part of progress so labor
inputs not going to grow much at all so
it's all going to have to be output
output per hour and output per hours run
well under 1% of late do you think the
economy is going to grow two percent on
average over the neck over the next 10
years recognizing that it's kind of
going gangbusters now if you look at the
employment employment reports but most
people expect first quarter GDP to be
somewhere below one and a half so what
do you expect the growth rate to be over
the next decade well one of the
misfortunes of working at the Council of
Economic Advisors as you get to produce
on the annual forecast that underlies
the budget and cooperation
with OMB and Treasury so we have put our
number on it which is two point three
percent over the next decade that comes
from the type of growth accounting
exercise that you were just going
through looking that GDP growth comes
from how much output you get per hour on
how many hours the hours depend on the
number of people how many of those
people are working and how much they're
working as I put all those together I
don't know that I was doing it very
differently than you were just
implicitly the growth in the number of
people will certainly be slower in the
future and that has a far-reaching set
of economic implications my colleague
Jim stock who's here was at the Kennedy
School the economics department now has
taught me an awful lot about them and
done a lot of research on them so the
biggest difference between our economy
now and for example the fabulous growth
Reagan had the 1980s was simply that the
prime age population under President
Reagan was increasing at nearly two
percent a year now the prime age
population is actually declining so you
want to adjust for that first of all
once you've adjusted for that we could
have productivity growth above two
percent hours roughly stabilizing
participation stabilizing but a lot of
that's going to depend on our choices
you know you talked about the
participation rate declining if we had
more support for child care more
flexible workplaces and less of a tax
penalty for secondary earners we
wouldn't need to see the same types of
decline in the participation rate that
you were building into your forecast is
your two-point-three percent estimate
and estimate that corresponds to your
best guess of what will happen or is it
an estimate of what you think will
happen if all the wise policies that
your administration has proposed you
know immigration reform support for
support for working women trade
agreements tax tax reform is the 2.3 an
estimate of what's going
happen or is it an estimate of what
would happen if all your good ideas were
implemented the long-standing convention
and administration forecast is that
they're based on the president's
policies and assuming the enactment of
the president's policies which I fully
expect to happen you do I hope your hope
your economic forecasting is better than
your political forecasting um though I
share your hope that meant and in the
vast majority of cases I share your hope
that the policies will pass suppose the
president's policies were not to pass
and suppose we were to remain roughly
gridlocked and you know when there were
hurricanes we voted emerged we we voted
emergency assistance and when there were
Wars we sent our troops to them but we
didn't undertake unforced moves to
improve economic performance what would
your estimate was your estimated a
growth rate of the American economy be
then I don't want to recompute a
forecast here in my head right on stage
but it would certainly be lower than
what I said it's going out on a limb um
thee and how much do you think it
matters to America's position in the
world if we're growing in a two-percent
range rather than the three-percent
range that we used to think of as normal
I think first of all you do need to
adjust it for the change in the
population if your population is growing
at ten percent a year and your economy
is growing at three percent a year now
people are going to be a whole lot worse
off year after year if your population
isn't growing at all and your economy is
growing at three percent a year people
are going to be better off so just for
the position of Americans within the
United States you need to make that
adjustment and if you make that
adjustment one you wouldn't expect to
see as much growth if the workforce
isn't growing as quickly and number two
you wouldn't need to see as much growth
now the workforce itself is not a
demographic fact that's inscribed in
stone it depends on our choices and one
of the most important choices it depends
on is immigration reform and that
slowing growth of our population is one
of the big motivations for immigration
reform which we can come back to the
second issue which is just relative
standing of the United States in the
world in the United States has it market
exchange rates the largest economy in
the world it will always have one of the
largest economies in the world but we're
never going to have the largest
population in the world and so at some
point you'll see you know some set of
changes and as long as those changes are
the United States continuing to have the
lead role in the world setting a
transparent set of rules and norms an
economy on the model that's been
successful for us in so many other
countries in the last decades I think
that that could be a perfectly bright
future for us and for the world someone
said to me the other day that the only
economy that's grown is rapidly in the
world as China or close to as rapidly in
the world as China on a per capita basis
was richest and richest and being
defined as the top one percent of the
american population that has seen income
growth over the last generation at the
six to seven percent a year basis in
real terms what what's your way of
understanding how that's happening how
big a problem do you think it represents
and if you think it represents a problem
what do the president did you want to do
about it when you start talking about
the sheriff top income of income going
to the top 1% for some people that can
sound your big rushing success people
have all sorts of great ideas they get
rewarded for them I think if you do the
do love it
talk about what share of income is going
to the bottom ninety percent it was
sixty-eight percent in 1973 around fifty
percent in 2013 so from two-thirds of
the economy going to the bottom ninety
percent down to half of the economy
going to the bottom ninety percent you
combine that with the fact that
productivity growth since 1973 was
slower than the decades before it and it
means that incomes for the typical
household are going up at about four
tenths of a percentage point per year
according to the most expansive
definition of income produced by the
Congressional Budget Office to me that
seems untenable substantively to some
degree that's a value judgment to some
degree that's a judgment about what it
means for the future of our economy when
you compare it to the three percent
income growth we had in the decades
before it for median households or when
you compare it to as you said the seven
percent growth you see for households at
the very top so I think know once you
frame it that way to me it seems like a
rather urgent public policy problem that
problem that I would define as what you
can do to raise the incomes of the
middle class part of that is going to be
a more progressive tax system because
that's one thing we know how to do a
more progressive tax system I think
doesn't just affect the after-tax
distribution of income I think programs
especially the damed it households with
children like the Earned Income Tax
Credit have been proven to have benefits
for income mobility for house children
do nutritionally how they do in school
and thus how they'll do in the next
generation the larger goal though is a
set of policies that would more directly
affect before tax incomes and you're a
little bit harder to quantify they're a
little bit harder to understand and you
know to some degree there anything that
raises growth so I think of you know
trade to talk about something we had
mentioned before I think of that as
no class policy because I think it's
part of remedying the slowdown in
productivity growth we've seen in the
last several decades getting it to rise
and if that pie was expanding more
quickly it could raise incomes we have a
number of instruments that work better
at the bottom for example raising the
minimum wage moderate increases in the
minimum wage make perfect economic sense
at a time right now you know everyone
would love to see more bargaining power
for workers the decline in unionization
has directly mirrored the decline in the
share of income going to the bottom
ninety percent but you know thinking
about bargaining both in terms of unions
and more broader than unions is an area
that I don't think you know we 100%
understand the full set of policies that
are you know feasible and would suck
their but in some sense is the biggest
prize in this area of all it's a very
thoughtful Washington kind of answer the
in the buff in the following in the
following sense you said very powerfully
that the share of income going from the
going to the bottom ninety percent had
fallen by falling from two-thirds to
one-half which is about sixteen percent
of total income so the GDP of the United
States is about sixteen trillion for a
variety of reasons you shouldn't count
all that so let's count 12 let's count
12 trillion as income the ghosts of
people so sixteen percent of that is two
trillion dollars the whole earned income
tax credit is 50 billion dollars a year
so are you there's a set of stuff you
talked about amount to much against a
two trillion dollar swing and how do you
think about what caused that two
trillion dollars swing mm-hmm let's look
at the very bottom um and look at
poverty if you
to measure poverty just based on market
income don't count taxes and transfers
at all which is said something different
from the official poverty rate you
basically see it unchanged from 1968
through the present if you take into
account taxes and transfers the poverty
rate has declined by forty percent so
there you're obviously talking about a
smaller fraction of the income you were
just describing in a smaller fraction of
the people on that we were just talking
about but policy has made quite a large
difference over the last 50 years in
dealing with poverty now over the next
50 years do I think I'd be satisfied if
we come back here for a few years from
now market income-based poverty is the
same as what it was in the 1960s and we
I can tip report again that we've made
another forty percent reduction using
taxes and transfers of course not we
need to do to make changes in terms of
income that's a very bottom as you go up
the income scale because that's good but
that you know the central political if I
might the central political problem in
some ways for the political party you
and I are members of is not like
everybody thinks we really care a lot
about the poor and have delivered really
well for the poor the problem is they
all think the first and an awful lot of
people are unconvinced about the latter
in part because they don't look at the
type of data I just don't okay some
people don't think we've delivered for
the poor but they think we care about
the poor the problem we have as a
political party is that people who work
in cities in the Midwest and who belong
to unions and are genuinely in the
middle of the american income
distribution used to think we were on
their side and now they dont and thats
related to your four tenths of a percent
and so i'm trying to understand what our
what I how you see our strategy for the
1.6 you know to get it at two trillion
to get at that two trillion dollars I
prepared to believe that with 100 100
fifty two hundred billion dollars you
can do important things for poverty and
we are and will do more of those things
but what about the inequality that is an
important part of why middle-class
living standards aren't growing do you
think it's plausible aspire to reverse
so so having tried to narrow your
question down to poverty let me broaden
it to income as a whole because I think
it is really important to understand
that that's 0.4 percent growth isn't
just because of the rise in inequality
oh that's an important part of it in the
last economic report of the president we
did a decomposition we did a thought
experiment that said number one what if
productivity growth had grown from 1973
to the present the same rate it did from
nineteen forty eight to nineteen
seventy-three and what we found was if
you just did that thought experiment
incomes would have been sixty percent
higher in 2013 if you had frozen the
share of income going to the bottom
ninety percent at what it was in 1973
incomes would have been about a quarter
higher and if you'd continue to have an
increase in participation rate the way
you'd seen for women they would have
been about five percent higher so all
three of those factors the overall
productivity growth of the economy
number one inequality number two and
participation the number of people who
are working number three are what's
shaping incomes and I think we need to
operate on all three of those dimensions
number one in terms of productivity we
don't have any way to raise productivity
by ten percent next year to remedy the
problem you said I think we have a lot
of things that could raise productivity
by two three four five tenths a year and
then after a decade or two that really
cumulates up quite a lot and we've
alluded to some of those already in our
discussion in terms of inequality there
you know the you know I think education
has played an important role the
slowdown in educational attainment again
expanding preschool isn't going to
change those incomes tomorrow but it's
going to first of all fulfill
a notion of equality in terms of
equality of opportunity that almost no
one would debate and second of all have
large benefits in the future and third
of all have some collateral benefits
today in terms of enabling more more
parents to work who choose to work and
you know finally I think there's a lot
of policies I mean preschool be a good
example of it that operate on all of
those dimensions simultaneously that
expand growth that reduce inequality and
that help more people participate in the
labor force there's certainly things
were there's trade-offs between the
three and where there are we should
evaluate them in terms of what they do
for the incomes of middle class and
those trying to get into the middle
class but before we even get to the
trade-offs is an awful lot of
low-hanging fruit that isn't going to
solve the problem overnight but by tens
and tens accumulating over years and 10
years and 15 years really will make
quite a profound difference just let me
ask you a different kind of question you
studied for a PhD in economics here you
wrote very good thesis you were a very
good student in your graduate courses
and then you found yourself in this you
spent most of your career in this rather
different world of practical economic
policy tell the students here do you use
the models and the math and all the
stuff you you learned about in getting
your PhD in in getting your PhD as you
advised that as you advise the president
or do you use your political skill and
common sense
I think the set of arithmetic and
identities that you learn get you my
numbers are going to add up to 100 so
I'm going to contradict this very first
one that I said get you about forty
percent of the way on the number of
statements you hear not from the
president who really genuinely does
understand these issues very deeply but
the number of statements you hear about
trade for example that don't recognize
the set of national accounting
identities related to the connection
between savings investment in the
current account deficit or incomes that
don't understand compensation is the sum
of wages and benefits and a set of
identities like that get you pretty far
you add to that a certain amount of the
price theory you learn an introductory
economics so in a price of something
goes down you know the demand for it
goes up and the supply of it goes down
that gets you probably another twenty
percent of the way there in any given
area there's a lot of tools you learn so
you know econometrics tools that will
give you a way of dealing with something
thinking in terms of you know
differences in differences or how to
identify matters there are fewer policy
issues than you like that there's a
paper off the shelf that you can find
that already answers it a lot of what
you're interested in is things that have
happened in the last few years that
people haven't written about yet or some
policy topic like what to do about over
time that you discover most of the
literature is 20 years old so there's a
lot of less that you can pull off the
shelf than you'd like and more that you
have to invent the last thing that I
think is best about universities in a
lot of ways is Washington a lot of
policy discussion turns into a team
sport and there's people on your side
and there's people against you and no
matter what you say the people on your
side think it's great the people on the
other team think it's terrible and you
suspect that the reason they think it's
terrible isn't because there was some
flaw in your thinking but because they
have some agenda to you know destroy the
economy in the world in the middle class
that's not the way universities function
if you're in a seminar in your paper
reaches a conservative conclusion Robert
Barrow isn't going to be any more polite
to it as a result of that and you know
the converse is also true so I think
that habit of thinking that you get in a
university and I think you get it
particularly well in an economics
department or is one of criticism debate
exposing assumptions trying to figure
out what's right and wrong without
dividing it up into what I think can be
the little bit of the brain deadness of
teams and I think that attitude and
discipline is 1 i've tried to take into
policymaking and really think more
critically try to figure out if things
are right or wrong subject things to
scrutiny because i think if you care
about the middle class care about the
different questions we've been talking
about you know you want to you want to
work hard to figure out if maybe
something you're doing is wrong or
should be done differently what worries
you most about the United States are
going to look future it's again
middle-class income growth and I would
say I think productivity growth is the
most important lever for that both
because it directly feeds into income
also because it determines on what our
fiscal future is and how much will be
able to afford to solve the problem
insofar as it's not solving itself one
of the things that's happened since you
graduated from Harvard is I think it's
fair to say is that our students are on
average at least as idealistic as
students were when you graduated from
Harvard but the fraction of them who
find government to be an attractive
direction for their idealism has gone
down and the fraction of them who think
that working in NGOs or work
nonprofit organizations or some
alternative non-political non
governmental activity is the best way to
make a contribution to making the world
a better place has has gone up and some
of that because exciting things have
happened in the NGO sector but some of
that reflects a growing disillusionment
with government as a mechanism for
contributing to the world how would you
respond to that trend no I think it does
take a certain amount of stamina to do
public policy there's a set of ideas
which are you know both sides actually
agree to and you can't get done and then
there's a set of ideas that are
screamingly obvious to me and you can't
persuade the other side to agree with
them and that you know is even harder
and nothing happens as fast as you think
it should but then you have things like
the last budget President Clinton put
forward that you know that I work done
we put in that a policy to expand the
earned income tax credit for families
with three or more children that came
about because I called Jeff Liebman I
don't know if he's here but he's
certainly Kennedy School professor and
asked him what we should do about
poverty he said expand the earned income
tax credit for three children I said it
to Gene Sperling Jean said it to Larry
and we put it in the budget needless to
say the budget that President Clinton
put out in February of 2000 was not
enacted in full in fact it wasn't
enacted at all I got out of the
administration and continued to be taken
by the idea so the center for american
progress was organizing a conference on
tax reform and i decided to focus on tax
reform in poverty and centered around
that as well as some related set of
ideas the obama campaign took the exact
same set of parameters in the paper that
i had produced for the center for
american progress policy and put it into
their campaign platform he was elected
I was on the hill negotiating a lot of
the Recovery Act I'd put the exact same
thing into the Recovery Act it's since
been extended through 2017 and I think
it'll be made permanent and it's
benefiting about 10 million people a
year you know in some ways that's more
than you can do in a lot of NGOs I don't
have ten other examples like that I know
ten other people that put something else
in to President Clinton's budget last
budget that didn't subsequently happen
so I'm not saying that that story is
going to always work or work for
everyone but certainly when I think
about myself and what I do in public
policy nine years was in some ways
frustratingly long to wait for something
that seemed like a good idea to me I'm
in retrospect you know it almost I feel
slightly better you know for the waiting
okay we are now going to turn this to
the audience there are four microphones
and there are a set of Kennedy School
instructions that I am supposed to give
which are that questions end with a
question mark appropriate questions are
in one part and our brief and we will
move we will move around the wheel move
around the room I hate to disagree but
multi-part questions always give the
answer the opportunity to choose what to
answer okay well then in deference t in
deference to our guests we will allow
two-part questions mister please
introduce yourself to i'm leonard elman
i'm an emeritus professor of medicine at
Harvard mr. Herman you cited
personalized medicine is one of the
bright spots in the economy and I would
certainly agree there were in the midst
of a biotechnology revolution but one
facet is the costs particularly in the
area of oncological
each new biotechnology medicine seems to
start at a hundred thousand dollars per
patient per year and many people feel
that the system is unsustainable and I
was wondering how you and professor
Somers think that this may play out in
the future so let's just look at the
firt last few years and use that to see
what we can about the the future health
cost growth measured by the CPI the
amount of costume lion aspirin abaya
treatment is growing the slowest rate
it's grown in 50 years if you look at
health costs per enrollee for
beneficiary and health insurance those
are tied for the lowest on record and
then you look at total national health
expenditure adjusted for inflation and
population the three with slowest years
ever recorded our 2011 2012 and 2013 of
those three that I talked about the
first two are continuing on into 2014
and 2015 based on all the data we have
the third total national health
expenditures is having a level change up
as we expand health insurance to more
people but it's not one that has
collateral impacts on the people already
have insurance their costs are
continuing to grow slowly so I think
contrary to the premise of your question
we're going through a period of slower
health cost growth initially this was
dismissed or not recognized because
people thought it was a byproduct of the
recession as the economy gets
increasingly stronger that notion is
increasingly less tenable as the primary
explanation of it moreover you see the
slowdown in areas like Medicare that are
in cyclical you see it in health prices
more than quantities and prices of life
cyclical than quantity so having ruled
out that explanation of the recession
which we think of as temporary that
leaves a range of other explanations a
number of which are permanent I think
part of it is just what we've done
to the growth of the way in which we
reimburse in Medicare we're shifting our
payment models away from fee-for-service
putting a greater emphasis on value on
bundled payments and so I think a number
of these changes are in the you know I
don't know eighty percent or whatever it
is a health costs at aren't drugs are
resulting in quite slow growth within
drugs itself you have contrary movements
you have drugs coming off patent
lowering prices you have this set of
developments raising cost growth but I
think overall if we get our incentives
right we can take advantage of a lot of
these developments to continue to have
at least some of the slowdown in health
costs that we've seen in recent years
persist going forward hi my name is Ben
vulture and I have a Harvard alumnus
question for actually both of you
looking back historically United States
made a decision to go off the gold
standard in the 20th century I'm just
wondering is that the modern economy was
there anything unexpectedly good or
unexpectedly bad about that historical
decision I think the fact that after
2007 we didn't see our unemployment rate
go up to twenty five percent and lose a
commensurate amount fraction of our
output in the way that we did following
a similarly sized shock in 1929 is in
part because instead of being on the
gold standard we had flexible monetary
policy were able to respond accordingly
and combine that with a vigorous fiscal
and financial response as well I would
add that Jason's answer is reinforced by
a consideration of the European
experience and the difficulties that the
that southern Europe is having are
closely related to the inability to
provide easy monetary policy in response
to conditions that would normally
require easy monetary policy and that
relates to
their membership their membership in the
euro I think in retrospect at least in
the context of a world like the modern
world the gold standard does not appear
to be an optimally designed monetary
policy system uh that segues well to my
question I'm sometime around the 1930s
what are you introduce yourself I'm
sorry your name oh I'm Jared Ruben sigh
and around the 1930s John Maynard Keynes
made a prediction about what's going to
happen in his grandchildren's generation
and he predicted that the workweek would
really go down and people would have a
lot more leisure but that really hasn't
happened right because the standard work
week is still 40 hours and a lot of
people work longer weeks and that so how
come all this technological progress
hasn't translated into people being able
to enjoy more leisure and is that
influenced by a bias towards maximizing
GDP instead of maximizing well-being I
think a lot of this reflects choices
that people make and I'm not going to
second-guess that set of choices and if
somebody wants is choosing between the
set of consumption goods and a set of
leisure you know that seems like a
reasonable choice to make we have that
income problem that we were talking
about before the combination of
inequality and productivity growth that
has slowed that income growth for a
while we were able to mask that as more
women came into the workforce and you
had more to earn our couples instead of
wondering are couples and that kept
incomes propped up to some degree but
you know I also think well i wouldn't
second guess those judgments or make
those judgments really a name of public
policy the public policy should be a
little bit more towards encouraging
neutrality and let people make that
choice and if anything you know by
necessity on public policy is the
opposite of neutral if
thing tilts towards leisure and away
from work you know outside of public
policy to have a national conversation
and ask the type of questions you have
it's certainly something I ask you know
myself as I work it's something that
there's some rat race element to life
this some relative status and income
element to life and said have a cultural
conversation about that seems to me like
a worthwhile conversation to have it
just feels like less of a public policy
problem really yes may I just add some
add something when i was in economic
enact n Teaching Fellow here 40 years
ago we taught roundabout the sixth
lecture to people in their freshman year
about how the supply curve for labor was
backward bending and the idea was that
as wages went up people work more and
more but then past a certain point you
got rich and so you basically had enough
money and so if your wage went up more
you would decide to work less and enjoy
leisure because you had enough money and
that we taught that in part because
that's what Keynes had said and we
taught that because a reasonable reading
of the data at that moment was that that
was kind of the way human behavior
worked a reasonable reading of the data
today is no longer that way people who
have higher wages seem to choose to work
more hours than people who have lower
wages and that seems to be the general
choices that people make and so as we've
gotten richer people can you can get a
lot more extra stuff by working for one
more hour then was once then was once
the case and so people decide to work
more people decide to work more hours
now we can approve of that taste or we
can disapprove of that taste but I think
the basic fact is
Keynes's guess that once you were able
once you were able to earn twenty-five
dollars an hour in today's or
thirty-five dollars an hour in today's
dollars you would feel like what you
should do is have more time off and yeah
i already had plenty of stuff has not
actually proved to be a good prediction
about human motivation and that's that's
why the prophecy turned out to be wrong
I first off want to thank you both for
coming tonight and speaking my name is
Eric hollenberg I'm a sophomore
economics concentrate at the college and
um so when he was working when Rahm
Emanuel was working on the Obama
administration right around the time
when mr. summers you were there as well
as mr. Furman um he said never let a
crisis go to waste it is why the quote
is saying that given the benefit of
hindsight and maybe that the 2020 that
it gives us looking back on the
financial crisis and question for kind
of open question for both of you what do
you think are some of the you know
bigger policy objectives that the US
government and the Obama administration
may have not capitalized on for variety
variety of reason as well as the
international financial community when
looking at you know the IMF or other
other bodies somebody still works there
maybe I can do what we did capitalize on
and Larry can share his regrets I think
we did ha we did quite a lot I think I'm
the fiscal side it's actually under
appreciated because people just think
about the Recovery Act which was about
750 billion dollars of net stimulus and
they missed the fact that after the
Recovery Act or another 12 pieces of
fiscally expansionary legislation
payroll tax cuts hiring sent to the
long-term unemployed tax incentives for
infrastructure investment support for
teacher jobs cash for clunkers etc that
when you add it all up together was
another about seven hundred billion
dollars so 1.4 trillion of fiscal
support in total and I think that
vigorous response together with monetary
financial and other policies as part of
why the United States recovery happened
a lot sooner
than most of the other advanced
economies and then most of the history
of financial crises we've been through
if I have any regret about that whole
set of things who is that each one of
those things took so much work and if
just the first time we put in a trigger
that said if the unemployment rate is
still above blank then such and such tax
policy will still be extended such and
such unemployment benefits will still be
extended it would have been a lot of
less effort and freed us up to do more
instead of sort of slogging through the
trenches on passing all 12 of those
measures I just described unemployment
insurance the long-term unemployed then
might not have gone away when it went
away in 2014 when Congress refused to
extend it and the time we had an extra
session maybe we'd even have those
triggers in place so you wouldn't need
to make the case yet again it would be a
little bit more automatic so trying to
have a little bit more of a not just the
immediate response but putting in place
automatic stabilizers that on a
permanent footing we're better would
have been something um I wished we we
could have done so I guess I
inadvertently just answered your
question I'll give you a different
different different answer there's a
standard technique which Jason's sort of
used in which i'm about to fully embrace
which is when you're associated with the
administration and you're asked what
your biggest regret is your biggest
regret is always the Congress didn't do
something the administration asked to
because that way you've expressed a
regret that you've expressed full
satisfaction with your administration in
2009 the United States negotiated a new
set of understandings at the IMF under
which the night is pond to financial
crises and in which rapidly growing
countries like China we begin to have a
level of influence and vote proportional
to their economic scale in the world the
United States led and drove and persuade
in all the other
trees to accept those changes which were
somewhat problematic for some of the
traditional European countries in
particular that we're going to lose
share five years five almost six years
later 181 countries have approved that
change so it's ready to go into effect
except one country has not approved that
change that country is the United States
as a consequence we are holding down the
capacity of the IMF to add confidence to
the world at a moment when there's
substantial questions in emerging
markets as a consequence while we have
all this rhetoric about shaping a new
global order the truth is to China still
only has two and a half percent of the
vote at the IMF and we're taking the
position we have taken the position
unsuccessfully that China should not be
able to start a global development bank
to do infrastructure in Asia and they
can quite legitimately ask excuse me you
guys have had five and a half years to
support a reasonable role for us in the
IMF and you have not done it and so we
have basically ushered in that change
with legitimacy on China's part and it
is a terrible reflection on our
political system that we have not been
able to find a compromise and it is a
symptom of a broader problem which is
that we have great difficulty getting
the executive branch and the legislative
branch together on international
organizations international trade
agreements and the kinds of steps that
are necessary for the United States to
be leader in the global economy my name
is Thomas and sua I'm a student here in
a case cool so my question is when asked
by professor Somers about what worries
you about the future you
mentioned climate change when the
current business-as-usual scenario we
are expected to receive very likely
highly catastrophic human and economic
impacts as for example quantified by the
Bloomberg's risky business report so my
question is in the white in your work in
the White House how high is it an your
list of concerns a when doing forecasts
and how does that inform your
interaction with other areas of
government who are supposed to work on
mitigation on climate change mitigation
I'm glad you asked that question because
it gives me an opportunity to remedy the
deficiency from earlier absolutely it's
it's a huge concern and it's a huge
priority and you know I think if the
question had come to me as the fate of
the planet rather than macroeconomic
variables that show up in your forecast
my mind might have been led to that
rather than where it was it doesn't have
a huge impact on you know the prediction
for GDP growth in the year twenty
fifteen or twenty sixteen it has a huge
impact on our future and a number of the
steps and this is important in terms of
twenty fifteen or twenty sixteen a
number of the steps that you can take to
curb climate change also have a side
effect of reducing a number of other
pollutants that actually do affect um
you know social welfare for example
asthma a number of other diseases that
people actually get today so it isn't
just about the future it's about today
we're obviously doing everything we can
in terms of the climate action plan of
which a set of rules associated with
existing and new sources of emissions at
power plants that CEA and when Jim stock
was at CEA worked really closely on and
we've continued to work very closely on
because we are convinced that the longer
we wait the more costly it is to deal
with that problem I'm going to take two
more questions
yes sir hello my name is Ray Fong I'm in
alumni apartment since i'm speaking to
two prominent members of the Democratic
Party you would like to ask you a
question I know it's going to be rather
tough may I ask you gentlemen are there
any policies traditionally supported by
the Republican Party that you actually
think are sensible and are there any
traditional policy supported by the
Democratic Party that you think may not
be so sensible or is it that every
single policy supported by the
Republicans are automatically terrible
and every single policy supported by the
Democrats are automatically wonderful so
let me give you two on that have been
more associated with the Republican
Party rightly or wrongly in terms of you
know if you did a vote count who did
what they associated with one is that
the United States has the highest
business tax rate of any advanced
economy in the world I think that's
problematic in terms of the location of
global investment and economic growth in
our country I think you combine that
with an international tax system that's
broken that further impedes
competitiveness I'm now going to add a
big caveat although it's one that most
Republicans in Congress 0 degrees right
now which is that we have that high rate
we don't collect a lot of revenue
because we have a lot of loopholes our
international system pretends it taxes
you heavily but it doesn't actually tax
you at all so it's a combination of
distortion without what you'd normally
get in exchange for distortion which is
some revenue and so I think reforming
the business tax system to bring that
rate down address some of those
loopholes and have an international tax
system that's more globally competitive
and better at a roading our tax base is
a step I think would be very important
to our economy second you know it's been
a long standing tradition for both
political parties in the executive
branch to support expanded international
trade and something
that the president's pushing very hard
right now it's something that frankly
has more Republican support in Congress
than it has Democratic maybe I'll let
Larry answer the other half because he
would have done those two I think that
preponderance of the evidence would
suggest that we have substantial
problems in the united states that come
from a tort system that is capricious in
its effects and is a substantial source
of uncertainty for business in many a
business in many areas and it could
valuably starting from medical
malpractice but moving well beyond
medical malpractice be reformed and i
think would be fair to say that
opposition to that has there's a lot of
opposition with complicated political
roots but i think we fair to say that
more than half of that opposition well
over half of that opposition comes from
the Democratic side I think there are
complex questions about cost-benefit
analysis and regulation and we do in
important respects and Cass Sunstein as
a professor here led the effort for the
first four years of the Obama
administration through so-called Oh IRA
process with you know and be do
cost-benefit analysis but we should do
more cost-benefit analysis before
regulations go into effect and I think
it's fair to say that the pressure from
Republicans has been in the direction of
more cost-benefit analysis and I think
and the corollary of that is that
there's been resistance from Democrats
and if I were the Czar we would do more
cost-benefit analysis
then than we do you know I think humor
aside and my putting one question to
Jason and referenced the political
reference to our political allegiance I
think one of the things that actually is
is gratifying and it's something that I
think students are struck by in the
course that Marty Feldstein and I teach
together that there is a great deal on
which serious economists who studied
economist studied economics agree on
regardless of some of the values
orientations that lead some people to be
Democrats and lead some people to be
Republicans so I think it would be a
very serious mistake to think of most of
the content of economic policy as being
economic partisan as being partisan and
that if you put Jason and Glenn Hubbard
together they would agree on a great
deal that was in the public interest but
was not in the end but would run into
substantial political difficulty and
that the gaps between what economists
think and what many others think are at
least as large as any gaps between
economists who are Democrats and
economists who are Republicans can I
just had one very small think that too I
think also there's more agreement than
people appreciate when there's
disagreement within the professional
discourse of people that have studied
the issues I think the disagreement is
narrower than it is outside it so even
on an issue that Glenn Hubbard and I
would disagree on you know how what
fraction of tax cuts pay for themselves
you know he or at least Greg Mankiw
would say fifteen percent of income tax
cuts are paid for by the economic growth
that ensues I tend to look at
assumptions that make the number much
smaller but that's a lot smaller than
the range of disagreement outside of
that
that professional fish just just to make
the point one more way I think most
people who've watched and everyone who's
watched who's been thoughtful would feel
that there's been enormous continuity
between the policies of the Bernanke fed
and the policies of the Yellin fed this
despite the fact that Bernanke was the
former chairman of george w bush's
Council of Economic Advisers and Janet
Yellen was seen as somebody who was
probably in the left half of the
Democratic Party and I think that
reflects the fact that a lot of the
judgments that economists are asked to
engage with are really technical and are
not heavily suffused with political
content yes so my name is Julian Duran
I'm a first year student at the college
and my question is regarding the housing
market so it's traditionally been a
strong driver of economic growth but we
know when there's excess leveraging that
becomes a problem but subprime mortgage
lending nowadays is on the rise Obama
loosened mortgage lending standards last
year so my question to you to both of
you is should we contain this excess
before it becomes a problem again I
think the problem we have today is the
opposite of the premise of your question
looked at no wide range of ways mortgage
credit now is a lot harder to get than
it was at the very beginning of the
2000s which is before the set of bad
mortgages that caused the problem were
originated financial institutions and
you know to some degree their
supervisors have overcompensated for the
crisis and so I think Fred it right now
is still too tight the pace of
homebuilding is about 1 million homes a
year just looking at the underlying
demographic growth in our country it
should be more like one
million homes a year so we're
underperforming relative to the
fundamentals in terms of building homes
and then you know finally things like
attempting to look at ratios of rent to
own and the relative costs of those you
know aren't you know don't resemble the
type of out of whack behavior that they
had in the housing bubble so I think
right now it's important for us to
continue to take steps to make sure that
more creditworthy borrowers get credit
where I think we haven't succeeded and
to follow the Larry Summers formula of
answering these is reforming our housing
finance system that's going to put us on
a more sustainable footing going
forwards or this moment right now in
credits too tight I think going forward
replacing Fannie and Freddie with
something else putting the risk you know
within the financial system and within
capital markets well before it gets to
the taxpayers having any residual
portion being borne by the taxpayers
paid for ex ante by fees is something
that's really quite important to do and
something that we're certainly trying
hard to get done you will have the last
question my name is yang qian I'm a
fourth-year PhD student in economics and
thanks for your conversation my question
is regarding the immigration policies
since I want to ask both of you what's
your opinion on the recent changes in
the immigration policy and what's the
effects of such kind of policy on the
labor forces and on the economic growth
as an econometrician my question is that
recently there is some debate on the
fundamental of how to calculate GDP and
what's your opinion on the calculation
of gdp thank you ah you asked the
two-part questions I hey I'm going to
mostly answer the first part at the
council Economic Advisers we took a
really close look at the immigration
executive actions that the president
took and tried to rely on a wide range
of literature that
out there as well as estimates including
estimates that the Congressional Budget
Office did and our estimate that was
that it would add about 0.4 to 1.0
percent to GDP after a decade it would
do that in part because it would expand
the quantity of Labor mostly on the
high-skilled side by letting some people
work who wouldn't otherwise work but it
would also improve total factor
productivity which is something the
Congressional Budget Office found you
see that you know most obviously with
high-skilled where higher rates of
patenting innovation entrepreneurship
job creation the United States but I
think it's also true if you take the
undocumented population here in the
United States give them more certainty
they can move to jobs that they're a
better match for make investments in
education or starting a business a
number of other ways contribute to our
economy as well so I think that
executive action will add to the economy
legislative reform to our immigration
system would add a lot more to our
economy almost a factor of ten more at
least than the lower bound estimate that
i just gave but that was about as far as
we could push it administrative lee the
measurement of gdp is a very big
question i don't know what aspect of it
you're getting at but i think our
statistical agencies do a very good job
of measuring it as best as they can i
think within the concept they've defined
there's a lot of challenges about
measuring things like Google that are
unpriced and then GDP doesn't tell you
everything so you shouldn't look to GDP
dancer questions that are broader than
GDP it should be one input into the
questions that you ask I'm going to give
a user answer as a usurer question as a
basis for giving a brief plug for
economics and then i'm going to give
Jason a chance to say a final word so he
should figure out what what he wants to
say um you know what comes to mind in
your question is an opportunity to
really say how economic research makes a
difference the there was really a good
natural experiment for
studying immigration had happened some
substantial number of years ago because
of a set of developments in Cuba over
about a two-month period an amount of
people that represented about seven
percent of the population of Miami all
arrived at once and so that's kind of an
experiment like you had a big increase
in immigration some people thought you
were going to yet only so many jobs and
if you had all these immigrants there
was going to be much more competition
for the jobs and so wages were going to
plummet and Americans were going to get
unemployed and other people thought well
is really a lot more complicated than
that because when people came yes they
took jobs but they also spent money and
needed houses and what stuff in the
grocery store and so it would all sort
of work out and because as a consequence
of the desire of economists to do
research there was actually systematic
data available that wet ones study every
few months what wages were in Miami the
question could be really could really be
answered and David card a distinguished
professor at University of California at
Berkeley studied the question and
essentially concluded much more the
second view that there wasn't disruption
and that doesn't resolve the question of
what u.s. immigration policy should be
and there's certainly controversy about
the details of his study but I think
it's fair to say that as a consequence
of a study like that most people who are
honest and thoughtful have adjusted
their views on what the consequences of
immigration are and I think the ability
of American universities to have
professors who do studies like that and
the ability of our system to have
economists like Jason who when they're
in government are fully conversant with
that literature and can translate it for
and other senior political figures
contributes to our having substantially
better economic policy and therefore
substantially better outcomes than would
otherwise be the case Jason a final word
we heard a illusion before to a crisis
being a terrible thing to waste and I
think in that moment of crisis in two
thousand nine and ten we did a huge
amount and because of that I think we're
very much out of the crisis we're not
all the way recovered the unemployment
rate could go down lower some of the
byproducts of it long-term unemployment
the participation rate people working
part time for economic reasons or
further from being fully recovered we
have more work to do on all of those but
we're way past on the crisis phase and
we're way into a normal recovery in a
lot of ways that's quite exciting that's
quite satisfying but it also means that
the next set of challenges that we have
that relate to on the set of concerns
that Larry was framing in his first
question around economic growth on the
set of concerns larry was framing in his
third or fourth question about the 1.8
trillion or whatever it was of missing
incomes for the bottom ninety percent
those aren't an imminent crisis it's not
that if you don't do something tomorrow
we're going to fall off a cliff or if we
do something tomorrow we could fully
solve it a year from now but they're no
less pressing and they're no less
important I think we've had a good
dialogue here about a number of ways in
which a lot of economists agree to a
wide range of policies I'd broaden on
the field from economists as an awful
lot of people in Washington including
you know elected leaders from both
parties in both chambers that agree on a
lot of a lot of the different policies
on that we've been talking about here in
areas like immigration on tax reform
education trade and you know but that
even that isn't sufficient to make it
happen you know it takes perseverance it
takes work
and to some degree that's expanding our
understanding of it to some degree is
taking something that we've understood
really well for a while now and figuring
out how to translate that understanding
explain it to people figure out how to
navigate the system and get it done I
think different people play different
roles at different parts of that process
so I don't think there's a right answer
to public service and NGO or you know
working I'm in an investment bank and
reading about these issues and talking
about them in your spare time but you
know or or being an economics professor
but I think all of those can can
contribute and all of those will will
have to cuz I think we have a lot of
potential but you know we're definitely
not fully realizing that potential in a
lot of different dimensions that we've
talked about today so thanks for the
chance to talk about all the chairman of
the President's Council of Economic
Advisers Jason Furman thank you very
much
you